hi there today I thought we'd just give
a quick look at this paper tree of
thoughts deliberate problem solving with
large language models in summary this
paper proposes a sort of decoding
technique like a way to use large
language models where you don't just ask
them once what they think and try to
structure your prompts really smartly
like something like Chain of Thought but
instead you do an explicit tree search
over outputs of the language model with
the language model itself valuing these
three states and therefore being able to
Branch off and backtrack and so on it
turns out this can help for tasks where
such a a pattern of investigating the
task is really helpful so the paper
proposes the decoding technique and
proposes some new tasks where they
expect the decoding technique to work
really well and then the decoding
technique works really well on those
tasks make of that as you will it's an
interesting idea I do think it's like a
small step into a new Direction Where We
mix language models with essentially
with programming with algorithms so I'm
pretty excited for that and this paper
is a step into that direction it's by
people from Princeton University and
Google deepmind and will go right into
it so the main proposition is this one
right here
it's if you simply prompt a language
model even if you prompt it really well
you say well you are a super helpful
helper you're so helpful you just help
me and everything and um I I want you to
make to do this task that's sort of
called what they call here input output
prompting input output means you specify
the task and optionally you may also
specify an output format so you may say
to a language model hey I have this task
right here I want to write an email to
my boss please write it in the following
format first write Dear boss then write
the text in between and at the end write
the signature more commonly if you want
models to for example output Json as a
response you say you know don't give me
a textual answer only respond using Json
formatted output or even more commonly
if you want the model to do a
classification task for example you say
don't answer in text answer with one of
the following four options right just
output the word and then you give the
four classes and then you rely on the
model only outputting that there are
other techniques like restricted
decoding that can enforce this stuff and
so on but in general input output
prompting simply says you ask the
language model what you want it to do
and optionally you give a you give a
um a specif a specifier for how the
output should look like in textual form
um that doesn't also optional in here
you can do some in-context examples if
you want so all of this is like like
this this is like prompting
this is like standard prompting uh today
then you have Chain of Thought Chain of
Thought prompting is a different
prompting technique where you instruct
the model to explicitly make
intermediate steps so you say you know
um please invent please write a song
about a little bird right and please do
that in steps so please first make a
like an overall plan for the song and
output that into individual faults so
you would instruct the model not only to
have to have a prompt
that's too fat
you would instruct it not only to have
to have a prompt uh
followed by followed by an answer but
you would instruct it to Output its
thoughts so prom goes here
and then you say you know write your
thoughts on each line starting with like
T and then the model is supposed to put
its thoughts right here and its thoughts
right here and its thoughts right here
and then at the end answer so you have
to input output prompt for this
structure right here
um you have to tell it please do this
but it turns out if you do that if you
do this Chain of Thought prompting your
instructor model to explicitly write
down the intermediate steps of problem
solving the problem is going to be
solved better than if you just ask the
model to just provide you the answer it
turns out and I think that is not there
are hypotheses around why that is but
it's I believe it's not yet fully
understood why exactly the Chain of
Thought prompting helps but hypotheses
are that it gives the model kind of a
scratch Pad
um like right here in order to write
down its thoughts and then the next
thoughts can refer back to the previous
explain illicit thoughts and not
everything has to happen sort of in the
weights the second opinion is that it
just gives the model sort of a longer
time to compute like it can since it
decodes more tokens it can sort of
invest more compute into a given problem
and you're leading it into the correct
Direction with these thoughts multiple
hypotheses in any case the next
iteration that this paper considers is
self-consistency with Chain of Thought
this essentially mixes jaina fought with
voting so you just do Chain of Thought
multiple times you just kind of sample
multiple times and then
you majority vote on the output that
obviously is only possible where you
have some sort of a classification task
um where you can assemble a majority
vote there's also another concept that's
not mentioned here but that is sort of
iterative refinement which comes in
later in the paper what you can always
do is you can always just append a
prompt that says consider your last
answer how how might you improve it or
consider your last unders do you think
it's correct if not please improve it
and you can sort of
add that onto any of these techniques so
there's lots of these techniques this
paper here considers the tree of
thoughts and the tree of thoughts is
here contraposed to the chain of
thoughts as in you can see it is in fact
a tree so you have nodes and you have
nodes branching out and some notes are
kind of abandoned which here in the red
and then some nodes are continue to be
expanded here in the green so this
represents a language model that I ask
something and then similarly to Chain of
Thought I ask it to Output its faults
but I can do that
multiple times so three times I go to
the language model and just ask it to
Output the first thought in the problem
solving step just the first one not the
whole problem just the first one and
those that gives me the three thoughts
for example right here one two three
then then as a second step so I finish
that step as a second step I take the
language model and I use it to
self-critique all of these thoughts
right here with respect to the input
prompt so I ask it something like hey
what you just output here as a thought
as an intermediate step do you think
that's a good step towards solving the
original problem and this relies on the
fact that a lot of these models like the
language models but machine learning in
general is much better at evaluating
whether two things fit together then
generating a new thing that's just it
just turns out to be like that it kind
of makes sense because you only need to
Output a number or a value or something
like this rather than generating
something it is the case so
even if you use the same model to
self-critique you'll get a better signal
for the critic than you get for the
generation so that's why it does make
sense that after creating something you
go and you ask the same model to
consider what it just did and how well
it fits so the model for example you
you'll give it all of these tasks let me
grab
you'll you'll give it all of these tasks
and then you'll ask it to consider and
maybe it will say this one here is
really bad this one's kinda good and
this one's like the best you can do that
in multiple ways you can just give it
ask it to give you a score or a label
from like good medium bad for everyone
or you can put everything into context
and then say hey which one of these is
the best please vote for the best and
you just sample that multiple times so
you get like a non-noisy signal
and then what you can do is you can
simply say well this one here the model
thinks is really bad so I'll discard
that and I'll just continue with the
ones where I'm more confident then let's
say we we consider the middle one right
here so we've eliminated the one on the
right hand side
and we consider it the middle state
right here again I sample maybe this
time four different thoughts
um
and again I ask the model
um hey what do you think of those four
thoughts and now here the the the
drawing is a bit wonky I think in that
it doesn't display the algorithm
like this this note right here should
probably be
well I don't know
um but let's say we do that and let's
assume that this here isn't like full
green it's also red so it kind of says
well none of these are really good
towards the goal so it's like no no no
no no let's just assume the critic says
all of these are bad in that case what
we do is we'd actually backtrack we'd go
up here
and go down to the next best top level
State and go from that and say well okay
here is the prompt and here is the
thought you output for this particular
node Now give me the next thought right
as we did over here but we found that
none of these continuations made any
sense so we try a different branch go
over here and now
we maybe output here it's just one but
we may be again output four of them we
prune away three but one of them is
actually good then we continue and so on
so I hope you can see this is a very
classic Tree Search right it's a tree
search you can do this this breath first
or depth first
um but it's a tree search essentially
with pruning an ordered tree search if
you will
um according to the critics value so we
always go and expand the node of the
tree that has the highest current value
assigned to it this is very similar to
yeah things like a star search or yeah
various various forms of tree search
they do say they keep it simple right
here and leave more advanced algorithms
such as Monte Carlo to research and all
of that for later so I hope it's kind of
clear what's happening
um
they themselves formulate it into two
different so into two different things
um
you have a thought generator that's just
generating one thought at a time so one
intermediate step of the problem solving
that you ask the language model based on
the input and the previous thoughts you
just say please make one intermediate
step don't solve the problem completely
just wake make one little step and
explicitly write down the result of that
step that's a thought
in in Co in parlance
um so they say that's so we can either
sample or propose those which means that
we can go to the language model three
times and Sample three times for three
thoughts or what we can do is we can
just say please give me three thoughts
and then it outputs a list again we
might have to do i o prompting to get
the correct output format but we can we
can do that they say
um one for example this one right here
you might want to do if you generate
some story or something because two
samples are extremely unlikely to be
equal this one right here is more
appropriate when you have short
proposals but they're more constrained
so you want diversity you don't want
stuff to repeat itself but in any case
you generate Thoughts by sampling and
then you have a state evaluator where
you simply ask the model how good do you
think that is on either way that's value
or vote please do you give it all the
all the thoughts that have been output
and you say which one of these is the
best and then you count the votes with
voting it might be a bit more tricky to
do sort of
the backtrack like to compare nodes
globally
um you might have to do another voting
because in a different branch the the
winner node might have a completely
different value than in this Branch over
here but they they're both winners of
their respective votes but you can
Implement that in in various ways
um again they can mix that with BF oh
sorry with BFS or DFS
um just the
like in what in what order do they
consider things for um things for
expansion and as we said we can also do
that globally but for example in a DFS
they would go
they would have some kind of Maximum
steps that's that's fine
um they would sort all the candidates
they they have available if one of the
candidates is above the value threshold
they expanded so they go down down until
no node like until all of these nodes in
our example were like if all of that
these nodes are red they say are no
notice above the value threshold so we
backtrack
um this is it's not a like a global
expansion as I mentioned it I guess that
would be a step further
foreign
so I hope the I hope the
um the overall picture here is
relatively clear now let's go to what
they research is on or what they um
evaluate this on so this compared to
Chain of Thought right Chain of Thought
you can Implement in two ways um one way
is to explicitly always sample the next
thought but you might as well just input
in say you know put out all your
thoughts in one go and then give me the
answer so one prompt one sampling
because it's linear anyway right you
just want the model to Output a linear
sequence of things and therefore you
might as well sample it at once and even
the the self-consistency right here it's
just sampling multiple times in parallel
whereas this thing the big difference is
that you actively have to stop after
each step
um like sample three thoughts stop
evaluate dot One Stop evaluate thought
to stop evaluate thought three star off
and then you have to decide which one is
the best one and then from that point on
you go to the language model again and
say you know here is input and one
thought number one now give me
um three new thought number twos and
then and so on so this leads to a lot
more evaluations I want to say of the
language model but I'm pretty I'm pretty
excited that maybe in the future we can
just include this into our programming
language and say you know this piece
here I don't want to call like a
function that does something I just want
the the language model to take care of
this particular small part and the rest
I program around it and as we'll see
that's kind of the spirit of the
experiments even though I think they
they what they want to go for is like a
general Problem Solver I I don't think
this goes into the direction of a
general Problem Solver I think this goes
into the direction of like including it
into programming but the first um there
are three tasks to evaluate on one is
this game of 24. you have four numbers
uh for example this these four numbers
right here and you're asked to come up
with a mathematical expression that
results in 24 right
um so they what they have to do is they
have to prompt it explicitly right um to
to say okay give me possible next steps
all right here are possible next steps
then they parse that
um and they have this prompt right here
evaluative given numbers can reach 24
into these things again with examples
like with few short examples and then
um I I think with few short examples yes
and then the model outputs something
like good bad impossible so this here is
the thought generation and this here is
the evaluation and yes you can you can
reach like that you can get the language
model to solve these things and you can
probably do them better however however
they
um have to prompt it really specifically
here in order to do that which is fine
for research right but the the prompts
are really like like you would program
the algorithm except that the one part
is really taken care of by the language
model but the prompts are so specific to
the problems that they almost and this
is this is really so here we have okay
we have creative writing and in creative
writing you can see it's not that big of
a difference like if you if you if you
look right here the IR prompting versus
the trio fault like sure it's higher but
this is I think
um gpt4 evaluation and this is human
evaluation then sure this one here is
higher
um but it's like not that much of a
difference and especially if you have
these refine prompts then
you get up there too
so it probably helps more in these
algorithmic tasks and this here is like
mini crosswords so you have a grid of
five by five
let's do just do three by three for
demonstration purposes and it's all
letters and it's a crossword puzzle so
you for example here you'd have a word
um like let's say you have ape
ape okay and then here you have a clue
like
the life form
I don't know like like human
's are I'm I'm a terrible crossword Q
generator or something like this um or
like
animal with long arms that
lives in trees I don't okay there's
there's cues right here you know what
crossword puzzles are so
um and then here is like Poe or
something like this and then here it
says like poet Edgar
Edgar Allan and
okay so you have these cues and you can
input that into a language model and the
language model can output an answer
whether it's correct or not right that's
the question that's the task but you can
clearly see the task would profit a lot
from you being able to do this
backtracking because you know fill in a
word that you think might be correct and
you fill in another word and all of a
sudden you realize ah that doesn't work
out do you kind of cross out the ones
again that you previously filled in try
some other ones this is extremely handy
like in this problem like a backtracking
tree search is extremely handy that's
why they evaluated on it they're not shy
of saying look we evaluate the things on
the task where we think it's going to
benefit but
that that also should tell you that this
method
um is probably going to to shine well in
such tasks and it's yet to be seen in
like normal everyday usage how well this
does
so
you can see that in the input output
prompting in the baselines they say we
provide five example pairs in the Chain
of Thought prompt We additionally
include intermediate words in the order
of this or this we run each prompt 10
samples and average the result so Chain
of Thought prompt saying you know the
intermediates are you know the
intermediate words right here you don't
have to Output the full puzzle at one
point just intermediate ones and then at
the end give me the result
the tree of thought setup however is
much more integral in intricate
um
so they use depth first with with tree
of thoughts
um
keeps exploring the most promising
subsequent word clue until this state is
no longer promising then backtrack to
the parent state to explore alternative
thoughts that's the DFS tree of thoughts
algorithm they presented above they say
okay to make search more tractable
subsequent thoughts are constrained not
to change any filled words or letters so
that the Toots that has at most 10
intermediate steps for at each state we
translate all existing thoughts for the
state into letter constraints for the
remaining cues like this one right here
and prompt a proposal five times to come
up with candidates what to fill in
um
for State evaluations we translate each
state into letter constraints for
remaining Clues then evaluate for each
clue if it is possible to fill it
and then
yeah so
what I mean right here is that they help
a lot right and in fact which isn't bad
and you know the only criticism I would
have right here is that these these
things all the oh we translated into
letter constraints and so on
um I guess it would be possible to help
the Chain of Thought prompting like the
Baseline uh a bit by doing that as well
I feel like that should be possible and
I feel like for a fair evaluation that
should probably be attempted but in any
case
you can see they help a lot they they
help this process a lot to make it
really sure that you know the the model
um here you know you can see like here
it goes down this but then the state
evaluation says oh no actually this is
probably impossible to solve right now
not that you filled in these words and
you go back over here and try a
different route
so you can see this this Salon here
wasn't was probably not appropriate
um
However the fact that they help a lot
essentially
they implement the crossword solving
algorithm right they say in the text hey
our goal isn't they say it's something
like this our goal we know they say we
know that there are
algorithms to solve this
the goal is not just to solve the task
as more General crosswords can be
readily solved with specialized NLP
pipelines that leverage large-scale
retrieval instead of language models
okay so the they say you know our we
want to do a general Problem Solver that
explores its own thoughts and guides its
own Exploration with deliberate
reasoning as heuristics yet still they
essentially implement the crossword
solving algorithm implementing all the
three search and the constraints and and
so on
um and helping the language model to
such a degree that I think well they
essentially just replaced the lookup
from the vocabulary with the language
model so what we have right here is kind
of a random word sampler because all of
the rest is essentially implemented
um by by the the algorithm itself and by
the constraints they give
again this is not bad but it does mean
to me that the way I see this as I said
is in programming so in programming I
could have my code yada yada do this do
that do this and then here instead of
calling a function like f uh that
function would not be somewhere in my
code but that particular function would
be sort of maybe a language model doing
something somewhere and then I could
Implement something like a DFS or so
um and try to call that function as part
of it but I don't see this at the level
yet of what I think they want to do what
they want to do is to have this General
thing that looks at its own thoughts and
explorers and backtracks and so on but
for that in order to show that that's
possible The Next Step the next paper
following up on that really has to go
away from these explicit prompts for the
problems and really has to do it such
that
um there is one prompt like I should I
should be able to have one prompt
initially like one surrounding prompt I
can describe the problem a bit sure but
I should have the one prompt and then
the intermediate steps they should all
be governed by one prompt right not by
explicit prompts saying hey uh here is
the here is the decoding constraints and
so on now give thoughts about this and
we parse it for you even with the math
problems they like parse it
intermittently and so on
um
none of that should happen it should
just be one prompt that essentially
generically says consider your previous
thought you know how good do you think
it is and so on
um it could even be a meta prompt saying
if you were to ask yourself how good
this thought is how would you evaluate
it and then use that as a prompt right
but that really has to be the next step
in order to make this a viable General
Problem Solver until then I see this as
a cool thing that we could use inside of
algorithms part of algorithms
um but that's a very different direction
what is good to see is they do a lot of
ablations uh on you know what the
pruning and the backtrack and so on
gives so this here is the crossword
results you can see the i o prompting in
Chain of Thought prompting they barely
managed to solve full games they
sometimes have word and letter successes
but not that many the tree of thoughts
uh obviously is much better and if you
they say this is pretty cool they say
hey if we heuristically if we Oracle we
know which words go where right so if we
always at valuation time so when the
model criticizes itself and selects the
best thought if at that time we always
tell the model what the best
um thought is then it goes up even more
interestingly it doesn't go up that much
right it just gets like that last bit to
solve many more games than it could
previously solve but the word success
and the letter success rate don't go up
that much that's pretty interesting um
so it just kind of helps it to be extra
consistent right and um yeah
if they take away the pruning like if
they never prune
um or if they take away the backtracking
so if they always just go down never
backtrack and go to another Branch you
can see that the performance it
decorates again interestingly it doesn't
degrade too much in sort of the success
rate it does degrade a bit but
okay it does the great I guess I guess
the numbers are fairly big but the real
killer is it solves a lot less total
games so the total games are kind of an
indication of if you make an a mistake
like somewhere then you might get a lot
of the words correct but the total game
won't be solved
um and so the total games is kind of an
indication of how well that planning and
so on works
all right that is what I wanted to say
about this paper all in all I think it
is it is pretty cool
um it is definitely a good direction I
feel there's a lot that can be done on
top of this to make it more intricate
and I'm excited for a future where
I'm obviously excited for the auto GPT
style that is thought of here but I'm
also quite excited for a future where
these these things are just part of
algorithms like classic algorithms mixed
with language models I think that's an
interesting World let me know what you
think that was it for me bye-bye